c'était un bon jour quels sont les
enjeux de cette 43ème session du conseil
des droits de l'homme il ya de nombreux
en juin lors de cette session elle a été
marquée hier par un discours du
secrétaire général antonio goûter res il
a souligné que de nombreux progrès ont
été accomplis en matière de des droites
de droits de l'homme tout simplement
mais il a aussi déploré que de
nombreuses violations persiste alors il
a lancé un appel en sept points alors
par exemple la le respect à des droits
des femmes la protection des humains qui
vivent dans des pays en crise ou encore
la sauvegarde de la planète pour mieux
protéger les hommes
donc un programme assez vaste mais assez
générales et ce matin dans la presse
d'ailleurs ce discours a été un peu
critiqué car ils ont reproché à antonio
perez de ne pas avoir été assez offensif
il n'a pas cité par exemple les pays
qu'ils commettaient des violations
mais le secrétaire général sambre
privilégier une autre stratégie
le travail main dans la main avec les
pays pour une diplomatie de coulisses
alors on sait que sergueï lavrov le chef
de la diplomatie russe va s'exprimer sur
la question du désarmement que peut-on
attendre de son intervention
oui il va s'exprimer dans peu de temps
la conférence de désarmement qui a pris
un peu de retard donc j'imagine
vers 11 heures il a hier soir le
ministre des affaires étrangères russe a
rencontré antonio guterres s ensemble
ils ont évoqué notamment la question de
la syrie et puis il va donc s'exprimer
lors de cette conférence de désarmement
avec deux objectifs en ligne de mire
première chose limiter la course aux
armements spatiaux dans un contexte d'un
projet de traité avec la chine
il faut rappeler que la france et les
etats unis sont en train de développer
leurs programmes militaires spatiaux et
puis la seconde initiative de la russie
c'est l'élaboration d'une convention
internationale pour lutter contre les
actes de terrorisme chimique et
biologique
voici pour le programme qui va se
dérouler aujourd'hui au palais des
nations unies à genève
katia pique nique en direct de genève
merci pour toutes ces précisions